hemos hablado sobre cosas que pueden
llevar a la desigualdad lo que thomas
piketty se refiere como fuerzas de
divergencia pero ahora hablaremos de lo
que él denomina fuerzas de convergencia
fuerzas de convergencia que son las
cosas que pueden hacer de este mundo un
lugar más equilibrado la primera fuerza
que él menciona es algo muy cercano a mi
corazón y es la propagación
del conocimiento conocimiento lo que
tenemos aquí son un par de gráficas que
muestran la propagación del conocimiento
al menos desde el punto de vista macro y
una vista regional y muestra cómo ha
decidido un conductor del equilibrio o
igualdad en la salida mundial comenzamos
en el año 1700 y hasta la revolución
industrial hasta cuando se desarrolló el
occidente o se industrializó el
occidente américa y europa comenzaron a
tener un porcentaje mayor de la salida
mundial mientras que asia comenzó a
disminuir su salida mundial pero
conforme llegamos a la segunda mitad del
siglo 20 y hasta inicios del siglo 21
vemos que cambia la dinámica el
porcentaje de salida mundial de asia
está aumentando cada vez más y esto
podríamos decir que pasa porque tenemos
una transferencia de conocimiento una
difusión de conocimiento del occidente
al oriente de técnicas modernas de
manufactura
técnicas de diseño técnicas de
ingeniería y todo lo demás y es por eso
que al inicio del siglo 21 así se vuelve
una potencia mundial tecnológica
aprendieron de occidente y en ciertas
áreas han mejorado dicho conocimiento
para volverse ellos mismos cada vez más
productivos así que esto muestra por
regiones como el mundo se ha vuelto más
equilibrado debido a esta propagación de
conocimiento también podemos ver esto a
nivel per cápita esto de aquí es la
desigualdad global de 1700 a 2012
divergencia y después convergencia se
grafica el producto interno bruto per
cápita como porcentaje del promedio
mundial aquí está el promedio mundial
que es esta línea horizontal en el 100%
ya que es el promedio mundial y vemos
que conforme avanzamos en la revolución
industrial el occidente europa y américa
cada vez más su producto interno bruto
per cápita como porcentaje del producto
interno bruto mundial pero esto dejó de
ocurrir recientemente en las últimas
décadas este porcentaje ha disminuido y
no es que su producto interno bruto su
pib per cápita haya disminuido sino que
su participación como porcentaje del
promedio mundial ha bajado y esto se
debe a que el pib per cápita de asia ha
crecido mucho más rápido debido a que
nuevamente ha ocurrido una propagación
de conocimiento esta propagación parece
tener un papel importante a nivel
regional
hasta este momento pareciera que asia
tiene un crecimiento en su participación
mayor que áfrica pero se nota que el
oriente está teniendo más presencia y
está más en línea con el occidente en
términos de capacidad de producción
riqueza por persona
pero capitán algo interesante es que
esto está a nivel regional pero que hay
del nivel individual hablaremos más
sobre esto en el siguiente vídeo